yo boo lakehead podcast special guest
man the homie wayno is here what's up
brother
welcome welcome man we've been trying to
make it happen for a while for a while
and
i i gotta i gotta go on record and
apologize for my lateness today oh
you're good man
i mean it's cool but at the same time
it's like bro like i'm the person that
like
everybody in my family knows i don't
play with time i don't play with
people's time so it's like i just have
to stress that
it's all good man it's all good um
congrats on the new podcast oh thank you
thank you
uh i checked out the first episode and
then i checked out some of the third
episode that just dropped yesterday yeah
um what give me like kind of because you
could have went a few different ways
with like coming out of
uh doing everyday struggle yeah um
i i like the direction you took but like
kind of you know introspective
conversations
i think that what's dope is like there's
so many gems in these early episodes
already just
right based on your background and like
how you've lived your life and stuff but
like what made you go that direction not
and not kind of go
something similar to what you just came
out of because like all right so
everyday struggle i'm not trying to
minimize nobody who's been a journalist
right that was they haven't like that
never was my dream right it never was my
dream to be
on a show i never wanted to be on camera
none of that it's just like
it kind of was the luck of the draw i
mean it came at the right time
and once i got into doing um once i got
into doing content
a lot of people don't know that like bro
i'm the person that stays at the barber
shop for two hours because
we're gonna talk about basketball right
we're gonna talk about family we're
gonna we just that's what we do
in the barber shop so i was like i want
to bring my perspective on the things
that i'm into and the things i care
about as opposed to just talking about
music all day
music is my life it'll never go anywhere
right and for the people who
are fans of my music commentary i got
[ __ ] coming for that
but for what i wanted to do with wayne
was um with him
was basically talk about what's going on
in the world
um share my perspective and share my
story so that people don't
people think i dropped on the earth like
when i did everyday show right yeah for
people who didn't know like who you were
like you they were like who was this guy
yeah yeah but but
but even even with saying that who is
this guy's like it's a story to who this
guy is of course of course
it's not just music it's like you know
me being a parent me being a
husband me being a father me me being my
mother's son
is it's all these different things that
i want to talk to with people
so that they can realize like who i am
and feel like
look at me and say oh [ __ ] like if he
did it i could do it or if he did it
like
[ __ ] his story might inspire me where
i'm at and make me want to go on my path
and and do what i want to do so that's
why i did it
yeah because i i had known you because
we had conversations
about dave east when you were working
with dave um and then
i saw you on there was that weird
stretch
after joe budden left everyday struggle
when they had star on there
and that [ __ ] was whack because it was
almost like they're kind of both the
same dude there was like no voice of
reason in the room bro a lot of you know
the thing with star
a lot of people get star flag bro when i
was in high school i used to wake up
early in the morning
no i mean he's a radio legend yeah but i
think the thing is is that like
because even me i didn't know nothing
about what i'm doing now
right i started but like star i love
star for who he is i love that him talk
crazy but it's not the same platform
it's not the same platform and i think
when you have him and academics
it's almost like there's no like voice
of reason in the room that's really
but yo academics he does have voice of
reason but everybody wants to combat it
i think the thing is is like
you know we accept the message depending
on the messenger
and like some of the messages that he
may have
if you be around him and you sit with
him and you know him it makes sense
right but if you don't know him you're
like who the [ __ ] is he to say something
why why should he have the right to it
should be me or it should be somebody
else or it should be
and he he says a lot of [ __ ] that man he
say a lot of [ __ ] that don't make sense
to me
right that's my brother though like i
[ __ ] with no matter what yeah i think
for me like the academics thing i think
that
i've always had a lot of respect for
somebody who literally built up a
platform from their bedroom
right right you know what i mean and
you're right like he's had
some wild [ __ ] that he'll say like but
you know what i learned
from about the wild [ __ ] that he says
you gotta remember bros like i always
look at life is like
life is a movie and everybody's playing
roles right in different roles a lot of
people don't know the rules that they're
playing
he's fully aware of the role he's
playing and he knows how to enter he
leans into it he leans into it he
knows how to entertain within that role
see when i got bro when i got on
everyday struggle
i never entertained nobody in my life
mm-hmm like i i come from the hood like
i don't say that it's a mindset it's not
just a place i come from a hood right i
come from like a certain type of
background
so i don't understand i understand being
entertained but i understand how to
entertain
and that's what i learned from academics
you know what i mean like a lot of the
silly
[ __ ] he does he'll he'll wrap that
around a message but you you looking at
all the other [ __ ]
and you by the time you get to it you're
like uh he kind of got a point but [ __ ]
him
because we don't like him that's all it
really is but people just don't like him
but they don't know him
yeah i think that you know with him
i think there was just a few things that
happened i think the freddie gibbs thing
oh get yeah the gift statement was the
funny [ __ ] about the gift [ __ ] bro it's
like
we was a we did complex con mm-hmm
and we went to a party me him and this
is the first time we had ever been
outside all together
okay okay because act don't go nowhere
like people like i'm gonna run that
you're not running down on him no
because he don't go anywhere like right
so we went to this party it was on on
sunset
and gibbs was this way lee was there and
gibbs was really cool like it wasn't no
no [ __ ] but this was prior to prior
to prior to the craziness crazy yeah
surprise to the craziness but i i feel
like
gibbs is smart in that space too because
he knows how to entertain like he leaned
into it he leaned into it man he made
the t-shirts and all that
when he did the game of thrones [ __ ] he
put my face on and the desk of it like
the memes was funny like it just was
funny right i mean but act like
you got to remember bro it's just you
take a dude
oh yeah he he he built his you want to
call it an empire you want to call it
some [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever you got to call
it empire man whatever you want you
gotta give that man
his respect everybody got a different
definition right but
whatever he built he built it himself
and
not only the thing that i respect about
academics is
before he went and bought his self this
big old crazy house he bought his mother
a house
right you know i mean his they came here
from jamaica you know i'm saying like
he got good family like if you meet his
i never met his mom but his brother is
my my god
you know i mean you meet people around
him you'd be like how the [ __ ] he turned
like that he just wanted to be an
entertainer he's like a wrestler bro
i was gonna say he's like the paul
heyman of hip-hop
like he just got that you know he's
talking all that [ __ ] yo but you know so
crazy about that conversation you know
how people always say rap is wrestling
because they call it fake
wrestling is more real than rap than me
it's way more real and rap because i
don't disagree because the thing because
i'm a big wrestling fan so
it is wrestling is more you actually get
[ __ ] up in resolution break your
i took my son i surprised my son at
monday monday night raw like five years
ago right
the most entertaining [ __ ] i've ever
seen especially if you're sitting like
like really close up there but it was no
but it's amazing
but the reason why i said because like
the problem with a lot of artists is
that
they don't know that they're playing a
role you know what i mean like
they you you think that you're doing all
this real [ __ ] when you really trying to
sell a product
did you see joe rogan talking with
undertaker about um
i watched that whole podcast that [ __ ]
was a because you couldn't tell me when
i was a kid that undertaker wasn't
a demon possessed and paul barrow was
controlling him with the [ __ ] earth
of course like i really believed that
yeah but think about like
well he was talking about like when he
he purposely when he would leave
and like be in hotel rooms he would
purposely wear all black
yeah yeah he leaned into the camera he
leaned into it no matter what so the
problem the thing i have the reason why
i'm saying that is because it's like
if a rapper if an altercation happens
and a rapper who raps a certain way
doesn't react a certain way
everybody oh he's fake or he is or he
that if if we
was across the street and and shots
started flying and i seen arnold
schwarzenegger i'm not looking for him
to pull out the desert eagle and start
clapping people
you know what i'm saying yeah he played
he played his role and i feel like not
enough
artists uh they don't have the freedom
to just play their role well that's
that's there's an interesting
conversation about that right i just
um we just released the interview with
211 um
who used to be i remember 211 from um
yeah so he just actually put out a whole
project was like gibbs on like nine
records it's like it's like low-key like
a freddie gibbs collab album
but we were talking about the jeezy
gucci versus battle
and and he's got his problems with jeezy
yeah um
and he was saying essentially that jeezy
played himself and i was like well look
on the other side of the coin
jeez you know jeezy kind of showed
a whole generation that you know it's
it's
not very touchy it's very touchy because
someone died somebody
see that's the thing right like i've
everybody talks about what they would do
in that situation until they're in that
situation
i've never i've i've my first friend
that i've ever had in life is tattooing
on my arm he got murdered i don't know
how i would feel if i saw his killer
right like i don't i know that i know
for a fact i'm not trying to go to jail
just just just to think that i'm making
people happier to give myself some
satisfaction by taking his life
you got kids to worry about i got a lot
of [ __ ] you got you got your livelihood
your career everything so i'm not like i
can't speak
that's one thing i can't do i can't
speak for why gz felt like he should
have did that but i know why gucci did
it
don't say it like i understand why he
did it because if i'm on the other side
of the coin i probably would have did
the same [ __ ] he did
yeah i think that um like you said like
there's there's like especially with
these
there's you know a lot of these kids in
these younger generations like you look
like what's going on in jacksonville
with the hip-hop [ __ ] right now it's
so insane wow yo kev i just say as a
black man this [ __ ] dishes me
to see like like when i was growing up
listening to music we all we grew up on
the same music yeah
i never heard nobody like like when it
was when artists would diss each other
they might have had a problem backstage
or something but it was more centered
around you
it was more centered around the hip hop
the bars
it's just like and sometimes there'll be
some personal [ __ ] involved
but it was never like but the thing
about it is
would i be finding out with a lot of
these stories is like all right
these kids be getting into a lot of this
[ __ ] when they're like when i was 14 i
got into a lot of stupid [ __ ]
but like these kids it'd be like y'all
played basketball together or y'all used
to sleep at each other's house or
his his aunt is your mom best friend and
y'all ha and then y'all
now y'all just super murderers like you
know what i mean and the
the thing about it is like nobody don't
talk about like the post trauma with
these kids go through
no everybody sit here act like
they just is murder and killer they're
not talking about like the piece of
their self they lose when they might
have did some [ __ ] like that
you know what i mean yeah man the waking
up the night i like i think about like
the young and ace kid who put out the
record yeah
the whole world bro it's
so crazy but i've met him and
interviewed him and he seems like a nice
genuinely like sweet kid and then he
puts out and then the other kid puts out
a record
on the the graveyard of his like it's
like
it's crazy like where the hell don't
know bro but you know what's crazy most
of the artists that i meet
cause this is the thing i've been in
this [ __ ] bro i i was
i was really brought up in this [ __ ]
around state property right i'm saying
so it's like
which we'll get to yeah but i'll just
say this before we get to that
beanie siegel might be the toughest
person i've ever met in my life i mean
when he when he was at that time
but who he was to everybody when we came
out the house because i lived with
beanie segal when he was on house arrest
who he was
when we came out the house was a
different person than where i knew him
how i knew him how his mother knew him
his kids knew him so i understand that
like
a lot in hip-hop we got this [ __ ]
this wall built up that we don't want to
like break down and
we ain't got no feelings we ain't got no
remorse we ain't got none of that and
that [ __ ] ain't the case and i feel like
a lot of that [ __ ] as me being a black
man is at the detriment of the black man
you know i mean because it's like i
would hate to see young ace or the
whoever the other kid he's beefing with
giano kid
but i would hate to see one of them go
down for some
crazy [ __ ] because at the end is bro you
hurting your mom's
like you in the opposite you got an
opportunity where you can build some
[ __ ] music has changed
so many people on this planet's lives
where it's like you got the opportunity
to like really
change your life for generations i don't
know if they care about that enough
because it's hard to tell a young
brother
to see that for i didn't see that far
when i was there yo but i'll just be
like
let's move your mic in the middle of you
oh okay boom there we go all right okay
better but like i'm just like yo bro
y'all gotta start noticing that y'all
have value when these record labels sign
you
and give you all that money which ain't
no money to them all that's cute
right but you have value that's the only
reason why they [ __ ] with you because
you have value now that value that they
see in you
you need to take that and build on that
and filter that into your family
because because bro nothing's realer
than putting your loved ones in a box
right nothing's real than that [ __ ] and
if you leaning towards that type of [ __ ]
you ain't
for nothing but destruction yeah i just
saw a clip of master p on the breakfast
club that i thought was dope and he was
kind of talking about how
um there was a lot of people who were
saying like
you know diddy had some responsibility
for black rob like you know [ __ ] like
that but then
p kind of took that into the
conversation of like you know
the bigger labels the you know the jimmy
ivenes or the the machines that are
behind a lot of the
these artists like they're not stepping
in and like
you know think about someone like nba
young boy who's yeah who like
like who like you know what i mean like
so if you know what i used to give
me a young boy a lot of flack until i
watched that interview he did injure the
yi
and hearing about that that kid's story
he don't know his father
right he don't got the best relationship
with his mother he's raised by his
grandmother
a kid need help and i when i say help i
he needs a shoulder to lean on he need
to and
it ain't just about the big homies
everybody who's not it's like some
yeah first of all like everybody was a
big homie and a gangster some [ __ ] like
that like you just need a voice of
reason around you
and you don't need to you don't always
need a person that need to have money
the problem with artists is they don't a
lot of them don't want to they don't
want to be helped
you know i mean a lot of them feel like
they don't need the help and i'm not
speaking for nba right
i don't know where he but like
the [ __ ] with with black rob and all
that and everybody holding
how can you hold diddy responsible
for somebody he gave an opportunity to
years ago
yeah right i mean that's 21 years ago is
when
life story came out right right yeah so
i was a teenager at that time i remember
buying that album yeah
so he gave this guy opportunity and i i
again i can't speak for specifically
with his because i don't know black
rob's story of course
all i'm saying is is that you can't be
held like just because you're the guy
with
that's the problem everybody count look
at his money and be like in his pocket
well well you should put him in rehab or
you should put him in this or you should
put him in that or you should have gave
him this i gave him that's like
bro how how much do you want for
yourself yeah also like
if like everybody who diddy's ever
worked with ends up having like some
real issues in life like you can't
like like that's so cute charity can put
you in poverty yeah no
that's just a crazy thing to expect from
anybody let alone like diddy or anybody
like yo just be
you know like how many artists did he
ever worked with you know what i'm
saying like
i mean it's been a lot but but i'm
saying but like if he's responsible for
you can't be held to the standard of
everything that did not work hundred
percent you cannot bro it's it's no
different than a basketball team right
it's like okay
like like all right who's the delante
west mark cuban shout out to him
shout out to mark didn't need to do that
he didn't need to do that but he did it
he did it
but everybody like why don't lebron go
get him why don't this person go get him
why don't that
first of all you don't know if he's
tried to or not right
secondly it's not lebron's
responsibility that's not his
responsibility
but thirdly if lebron mom slept with
delante west that's a whole nother
that's off the table i don't yeah
i don't know hypothetically
hypothetically hypothetically but
everybody that doesn't have it always
talks about what they would do with it
they lie
but i i even go call you a liar you
don't know what you would do unless you
guys you're not there people be like yo
if i had 10 million out
yeah all right if you got 10 million you
got 5 million in taxes
yup you got 5 million dollars you got 5
million then you got to fig
so we think of these cause we trained to
believe that these numbers are so large
and so much but when you get to those
levels the
level of responsibility heightens so
it's like yeah
you want to live like this you want to
keep maintaining living like this you
can't be helping everybody
because you're trying to maintain you
and yours i think that's the biggest
downfall of most artists that we see
is that you'll see him i'll see him come
up to the radio station and they'll have
20 [ __ ] with them
and they're from like down south so you
know that's 20 plane tickets
that's lord knows how many hotel rooms
how much is the airbnb how much is
everyone's food
you know what all that [ __ ] adds up only
people
i keep around me is people that i work
with
and when i'm working right right because
like
a lot of my friends don't do it like my
real friends that i grew up with
don't do what i do but it's like i'm not
just going to keep you with me for shits
and giggles
like if you if you're around me you got
to be working on something you can't
just be sitting around
and i'm just saying well what you going
to do man what you want to eat tonight
yeah what you want to do
no i'll take care of because if it's
something that we all are working
towards but i'm not just doing that
i'm also not a rapper that's fair i'm
also not a rapper
that's fair um you know now that you're
on the executive side you're doing the a
r thing for uh for asylum which is under
warner brothers um
asylum just got revamped well was it
last year because i remember two years
ago
it's a couple years okay okay okay yeah
yeah because before it was like i
remember it was like bunbee and mike
jones and mike jones webby
yeah boosie was dead yep diplomats at
one point
um what is your kind of thought process
of like because asylum is kind of like
there's some independent-ish vibes over
there even though it's under a major
yeah but you've been in the industry for
so long i always tell artists like
whenever you're gonna sign like you know
don't worry about the advance as much
because i think a lot of times people
will rush to whoever's got the biggest
upfront bag
yo so the thing oh what my fault i was
gonna say well and like to me like
that's
most of the time it's a mistake because
if you if you take that bag too early
the deal is probably really shitty
and you gotta be like you gotta pay that
money back but you gotta pay all money
back like
like it depends on where you at in life
it depends on where you're at in life
because i can't tell
i can't tell a young brother or sister
that's from harlem
right where i'm from or from louisiana
or from atlanta or chicago any place
where there's poverty at
don't take no money because i don't know
what your circumstances is right and
when somebody waving at in front of you
it's like [ __ ] what am i gonna do so i
learned this from my my good friend
steve carlos stevo
yeah um when you do a deal you got to do
a deal like right now i'm trying to buy
a house
yep right so good luck oh it's crazy
it's crazy you should wait well i'm wait
i'm waiting like
the shit's [ __ ] up right now she just
[ __ ] up it's crazy you gotta you gotta
you gotta you gotta
the thing is while it might be [ __ ] up
for others i don't have the same
situation everybody fair enough so
certain things work for me that might
not work for everybody it's fair that's
fair so
you got to get in where you're fitting
you got to figure out what works for you
best when you do a deal
you have to you got to understand first
and foremost when you sign a deal it's
not just a deal for you
that's a lot of artists think that like
when they sign the deal it's my deal
no it's both parties it's for both
parties yeah so when you're
when you when you sign for that bread
and and you you
all right you got the you got your your
check you could go get your nice car
you watch you have a nice night at the
club you can do whatever whatever you
want to do move your mind whatever the
case may be
you have to you have to immediately put
yourself in a position or put people
around you that
learn that know the business or teaching
you business because if not
you're gonna get [ __ ] over it's like
if i like we talking about a house yeah
i've i've been trying to buy one for for
a long time now right
but if i go sign a bad deal for a house
right
you think the bank gives a [ __ ] they're
going to get this back regardless
whether they put my [ __ ] in foreclosure
if i can't afford it one day and they
put my [ __ ] in foreclosure and somebody
buys it out and gets it or i pay it off
they gonna get theirs the big
corporation is gonna get this but you
gotta learn how to work within the
system
so i always tell people that like if
you're gonna do a deal no
it's not about that events it's about
the terms right about the terms it's
about what's on paper
if i tell you kev i'm moving out to la
kind of [ __ ] up but i need a place to
stay you like you know way no i got you
you could come stay we got this room but
you like it wayno
all right if you ain't if you ain't
gonna pay no bills in here i need you to
pick my kids up from school
i need you to wash my cars i need you to
do laundry on sundays when i want to go
to the game and watch the game [ __ ]
and i and i'm like no i'm like now ain't
doing all that [ __ ]
and you like you the one that you need
the [ __ ] place to stay not me
so a lot of people don't approach it
with a certain type of mindset well also
i think too
it's it's like based on the leverage
like you said it's just leverage it
depends on who you are
on your leverage so it's like i know we
we've been talking about gibbs right so
it was like when gibbs did his deal i
don't know none of his business
right but i knew that when he did a deal
with warner
he had done so much ground work and he
put so much work in that he knew that
the deal like me from the outside
looking at i'm like oh no
he gonna be good you know he's not
taking the deal that's because he he
he's turned down some of these yeah
right he's taking it and makes sense it
makes sense
business wise for the business he's
trying to run and then it's like
i can't tell you the amount of kids
brother i've tried to sign
and the deal might not be as much money
but it's better on the term side and
then they go across the street and sign
this crazy [ __ ] deal for all this
money
and nothing ever happens damn the
problem with
with these artists that they don't know
is that like these these are fortune 500
companies
they [ __ ] when you think of warner
don't think of
cardi b's at atlantic think about the
intellectual property of batman
and green lantern right you think they
give a [ __ ] about you streaming
you just said you you're not even a a
branch on the tree you a leaf on the
tree
now if they if they can keep this
business model running and going based
on how good you do
the thing about it is they give you a
million dollar deal guess what
big big labels could lose 30 million
dollars and the lights ain't going to
cut off the water's still going to run
the toilet's still gonna flush
but you feel special about that million
if you get a million dollar deal i tell
all the
if you go if you're fortunate enough to
have somebody give you a million which
is not a million
they probably gonna put 500 000 in your
pocket you got to pay everybody that's
in your business and then the other 500
gonna go to making your project
figure out how to make that 500 that's
working towards your project work for
you
get some producers sign them get a
studio build it
that's what i tell everybody i'm like yo
do not let like the biggest mistake i
see artists
doing is like getting into like one of
the like paramount
yeah they're in there for 12 hours and
half of that time is [ __ ] off eating
food
smoking and it's like yo like you could
just build your own
you got that budget take that money and
make your own spot whatever they're
paying for they're paying for the brand
it's like it's like i i
like i buy i'm not a big fan of like
designer [ __ ]
right right right but like every now and
then like i like i love louis vuitton
trainers right
drinks that virgil just died i love you
that's like one of my favorite sneakers
right now
but i would never buy pair louis vuitton
socks i would never buy the socks
right because i feel like man socks
ain't that important for me to spend 800
on right now sneakers is all subjective
right i'm not a sneak ahead i have a
love for sneakers
two different two different things um
i'm not spending that on but it's people
who will buy that
just so that i can show them because
they're repping a brand you care so much
about the brandon brandon brandon
brandon brand as opposed to getting the
work done and that's the difference in
the studio [ __ ]
you can you can record in the same mics
as a smaller studio as you can in a
large studio
now the person now you can bring in
that's a whole different conversation
right right and that's when you start
working with
a major label or not or you know what i
mean
a production company that comes in and
grabs a guy or not like you gotta
you gotta do what works best for you
nobody deals it's like social security
numbers everybody's gotta make all
different yep that's fair man that's
fair
um so let's talk about for people who
don't know
obviously you came into well you were
working in the mail room at the deaf
at the jeff def jam building originally
right you got fired
and then you ended up chasing down
beanie's mom you had her number no you
had her number that's not how i got in
though but
okay but you you would okay so how'd you
get into rockefeller
the way i got into rockefeller was um
omiya i always say this and i never
worked with her per se but omielly
macintosh she ran
um jay-z's fan club fan fam okay her
sister darren mcintosh
worked at rockefeller they from brooklyn
they all came up with jay and all of
them
what i did was is like i was the
youngest person in the mail room
so i was like i think 17 to 18 at the
time
i was 17 going on 18 when i got in the
mail so the rest of the mail room is
like we got a few rappers in there you
know what i'm saying we gotta yeah
everybody's like 25 and older but i'm
the young guy so when i come upstairs
like i'm i'm always i've always had a
personality to help and it's been
it's been at my my uh at my advantage
and my dad's
yeah me too but like so i'm the i'm the
kid who's like
i'm so inquisitive because i seen a
movie backstage and now like classic
when i seen backstage oh i'm seeing i'm
in the build i see tata walking in one
day i see lenny s i'm seeing all these
people
part of that movie was shot in my
hometown in phoenix so i and i was at
that show when i was like
so i was like i was at that concert
right right right so i went to see it
with my friends in the movies
but like i'm like i'm asking everybody
like how can i like how can i help and
omi's like yo you know
it's a fan club so they shipping out
t-shirts they're shipping out cds
whatever that people shout out to the
days of fan clubs too fan clubs the real
fans
right you know what i mean you really
subscribe and get real dope [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying absolutely
you got to write a letter to get in the
field club so i would help with shipping
so i would help with shipping only used
to give me tickets to go to like j
concerts and [ __ ] like that and then
i built the rapport with like i was on
the floors that i had was the royalty
department and murder inc was on that
floor
because it was a universal building and
then um you had uh what was the other
floors
i had to bring a lot of inner office
because people wasn't using email like
that right so it's in an office mail
so it'd be like only be like yo take
this second floor yeah take this to my
sister
at rockefeller right now so i'll go up
the rockefeller go up there
and i had built a rapport with them to
where i had after i got
fired from the mail room and i was
trying to figure out my next steps i was
working at a little sneaker store on my
hood and all that [ __ ] i quit that after
i've tried i'm like yo i need to do this
music [ __ ]
i just hit people up like yo can i i
didn't know what an internship was
i dropped out of high school in ninth
grade so i didn't know i didn't know
what career even meant
right so i was just like yo can i help i
just helped and i just sat around in the
middle room she was like the intern
without even knowing you was the intern
i was just sitting in the office and
then i i was sitting in the office just
sitting there doing whatever go get the
food go get the sneakers go get whatever
and then
i got an internship and then the
internship ran a little bit
the beanie calling his mom [ __ ] that
happened within that
and um then i ended up getting an
assistant in our position you know i was
working under my man big face gary
wow i mean who he just started a podcast
but um he was one of dame and biggs
homies that he grew up with from um
downtown manhattan and [ __ ]
the the days of interning and like
really like
really just like looking down and
working because that's how i got into it
i worked for free for two years at the
radio station before i got like actually
on the radio oh yeah absolutely you
gotta put your work in but that [ __ ] is
gone man well yeah no these kids because
we're like entitlement generation is in
full effect no super entitlement and i
mean
everybody needs to get money or they got
to see immediate payoff or they're not
they're like yo
yeah that [ __ ] is crazy that's why i
don't be like like i my kids
[ __ ] they get [ __ ] but then i'll be like
man i ain't giving y'all
like [ __ ] that i gotta work for that
like it is this [ __ ] is an incentive
your allowance is an incentivized
business right
allowance is a business for me i'm
saying here like my business manager has
to cut my kids allowance so it's like
oh you you're not cleaning up you're not
cleaning up uh
you ain't cleaning your room or you
didn't take out the garbage and now your
allowance is not enough for you to get
them pairs of sneakers
so now you want me to go buy you a pair
of sneakers now i ain't doing that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that no you gotta work
for yours all right
all day man um so once you
got into the a r position i know you
said you you know i think state property
i always
i got to interview beanie a couple of
years ago and that was like a real
highlight for me because he was kind of
exactly who i thought he was going to be
when he absolutely
um did not disappoint yeah and then even
like i just had young chris on the show
that's my dog yeah he came in freestyle
caught a body he's the yo he's one of
the best that ever dude bro
he came while later turned it over while
he came up to the station he had young
chris with him and i was like
while he's my guy but i was like yo
[ __ ] young chris yeah
low-key so influential his mixtape run
yeah
so underrated like those mixtapes that
he put out like kind of post the
rockefeller era were so underrated
but that was that was me and him man
because i was telling them i was telling
them about you bro i was telling them
about the mixtape [ __ ]
nobody listening 50 cent came and did
all this [ __ ] then i was telling them
about the
internet [ __ ] i was on i was on all
hip-hop i was on sohh i was in the
forums you know what i mean yeah
i used to be i learned forum [ __ ] forum
days bro i was on
the first where i learned forums before
i got into music was being on nike talk
yeah nike so i used to be in there
talking about sneakers and [ __ ] do you
remember the forum uh realistnwords.com
yeah oh my god i got all my mixtapes and
albums off of there that like when i
started bootlegging mixtapes and cds
when i was like 16 at the swap meet i
got everything off of there yeah yeah
oh bro the admin's name was porky he had
all the [ __ ] yeah i
yo i learned a lot but that [ __ ] was
like i was always
i was like the real early hip-hop
internet day okay player
chat rooms and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] bro
man yo they because they have forums on
black planet
like people would be on social media but
they didn't know that they had forums
for [ __ ]
so you going i used to be in the yahoo
when i'm 15 i was in yahoo check those
chat rooms
i was buying jordans online when i was
like 14 years old bro
there was like a whole chat room era of
just my childhood
my older cousin was like 19 and he was
getting [ __ ] off of chat rooms
it
that [ __ ] is crazy now but um
your run with uh with rockefeller you
were kind of
what year did you officially start like
were you like actually started to get a
check from rockefeller what year was
that
2002 like the end of 2002 but i was
there like
2000 i think like around the end of 2001
and also i got a credit sherry bryant
she's the president of the roc nation
right now but
me and shari is uh closer to age you
know i mean she's like a year or two
younger than me
but not to push your asia out there
sherry but but um
you're sharing yo bro shari was uh she
was like an assistant to carlene who was
dame j
and big's assistant and she was a kid
and she was running [ __ ] bro
and like that was the person i called
but shari's from harlem
so that was the person i called and
actually i just come to office and help
and she gave me
she opened up that door for me wow i
mean she told me like yeah come in
i pissed off mad times though because i
was doing what i was supposed to be
doing
but it it worked out i feel like you
were kind of uh
around the era of when like there was
probably some
background issues maybe starting to
fester
because i mean the rocket the
rockefellers but we didn't bro we really
found that [ __ ] out like
in the media we didn't like we didn't we
had no idea like because
i'll tell you one thing bro like one
thing about rockefeller that [ __ ] was
like
it really was like a family if you was
really because you had the people that
worked there
and then you had the people who was like
not too much like family and you had the
people that was really like
family family like we was really
tight-knit and like
i would be around dame and beans because
we at um we doing when we shooting state
property too
i want beans every single day i mean
because i ended up coming
from being an anr being like his
personal assistant slash and uh
so i'm around him all day and damon's
there and bigs and we laughing joking
and then
later on that night i might've got to go
to baseline and i see jay
and and bleak in them and it's the same
type of love and i'm a kid
so i'm green i'm just like i'm in heaven
bro like these are dudes that i watched
growing up and now i'm working with them
so it's like
you never think it's gonna end yeah i
mean so there did you see the
obviously i mean the drink champs
interview with cam was pretty legendary
today
did cam yo that's another ken was a
person that gave me an opportunity to
bro
oh really yeah i don't think i would
talk but cam like one day i was in the
office and cam
he walked in the office and like him and
jim walked in the office at the same
time and they look like they just was
arguing or some [ __ ] yeah and then he
was like he was like yo shorty
can't turn to me he's like yo shorty how
much money you make at rockefeller
a week i said two hundred dollars he's
like come to diplomats like you 400.
i was like all right like immediately i
was like all right double me up bro so i
get back to my block that night i'm
telling everybody like yo this one come
home with me is out
and you're from harlem and i'm from
harlem yeah so i got this tattoo on my
hand because kim had diplomat in his
hand just keeping the full disclosure
yeah i mean like i was influenced by of
course so
i get to the hood and i'm telling
everybody old kim gave me his number
that i'm calling him a hundred times and
he ain't answer but
what had got me to [ __ ] with kim was my
mom was a job developer so she worked at
this company
in the hood that like helped people in
the hood get uh
skills to go on job interviews so you
you come into this program you don't to
how to talk you know how i look a person
in their eyes shake their hand they
teach you all of that they teach you
like
skills like um word word uh whatever
that [ __ ] is i don't know microsoft word
all that other [ __ ]
and this dude that he had helped when he
came home from from jail
was like an older dude from ken block so
he would always
he knew me because i used to come out
come after you know after school go see
my mom get some money for lunch [ __ ]
like that
and one day he asked me like what i'm
doing and i told him and he's like kim
told you
i'm like yeah
because i was calling him a hundred
times right right right and like he
called cam and kim answered
and he was like yo you know that kid
that you met up at rockefeller his name
wayne oh yeah i had braised at the time
he got the braces like yeah yeah yeah
he's like yo
he like look out for him his mom looked
out for me he was like all right i got
you i got you
and that's how like cam he ended up
calling me i was working for diplomats
for like
two months wow and then went back to
rockefeller it was like i i was doing it
well he had to
like cam told the story in the uh drink
champs
that there might have been some sort of
animosity between him and beanie
it was like was that something you being
so close to be
like was that something that was real
hell yeah bro there was yo
let me tell you so all right look so you
see how
like right now like drake is the best
like he's great at subs like he great at
like underlying [ __ ] yeah he might
hi him and hope might be the two best
women yes
like you got to study that bro jay was
the be it's [ __ ] that i could tell you
that
jay talking about people that you would
never know because he used to tell like
chris young chris was really close to
jay
right so he would hear some people might
say jay got some flows yeah they did
but listen everybody of course of course
of course
but look but he would chris would be
like yo like we'd be in a room in jail
play a [ __ ]
and then he'd go tell chris something
and chris would be like
jay said that line is about such a such
so they was always throwing shots and
[ __ ] you know i mean like little subtle
[ __ ]
but yeah it ended up coming to a head
bro because like
like no they didn't really know that
like a lot of people at rockefeller
didn't know jay didn't know i was from
harlem
until i got the tattoo on my hand
because i used to be a christian all the
time he's like i thought she was from
philly right so my nickname was harlem
philly
harlem yeah they used to call dame give
me that nickname it was hollow philly
because i used to be with the philly
dudes all the time but like
it it it got a little when he was cam
was right
when it when it came to that that uh
executive position
yep yeah beans wasn't jacking that [ __ ]
i mean it was a jaguar yeah because it
seemed as if
uh nobody like like can be in the
getting that position at rockefeller
kind of hit everybody at it i mean it
would though
yeah it definitely was like you think
all right beans been here since 98
yeah bleak been there since before they
had the logo
you know what i'm saying and here comes
kim he's been here for two years but cam
a lot and cam turned that [ __ ] up
cam took full advantage of his
opportunity you know what i mean he he
took for
that [ __ ] he was saying about how they
made the office he made his own office
like even even down to coming in the
office asking me how much i may get paid
and he's like i'll give you 400 and then
i was in his i would come to his crib he
had a crib in jersey i was going to go
to like this condo he had new jersey and
just burned cds all day
wow yeah that means mixtapes mixtapes
yeah the diplomat mixtapes i was
if you had a diplomat mixtape i probably
burnt at least five thousand
you have the tower yeah the tower yeah
duke the guy had all them shits like
five of them shits and they burning five
at a time and i'm just
but it got boring for me i wanted to be
in the studio so that's why i kind of
gave up on that [ __ ] but
you know yeah like cam turned that [ __ ]
up in two years and
now that makes sense somebody come they
put the work in on the executive side
where you break
can put jewels on his first singles
first two singles yeah
like if you wasn't from harlem listening
to dj clue and k slade
and [ __ ] um who was around that time
i can't remember dj envy
you ain't know who juelz was like that
you know what i mean but he put him
because you well drew i was known for
rapping in the hood you know i mean but
he put you well he's
on on and broke him as an artist before
he had his first single
so he's doing the executive side of
things so yeah he deserved that position
but
that's a hard pill when you're beans and
yeah
no yeah uh you said that you were
roommates well you live with beanie when
he was on house arrest um
and i i always have shout out to my guy
dj damages from philly
well always but butt heads on the
greatest of all time talks and he'll
always put beanie like in his top 10 and
i'm like bro you're from philly so i
respected me
and listen and listen like beanie's got
classics and i think he's
historically underrated in that
conversation absolutely derek angeletti
said the real [ __ ] about beans one time
he's like yo he like a real life
dinosaur
he like you know how like you hear about
it like you you hear the stories about
the dinosaur but if that [ __ ] if a
raptor walked in this room right now
everybody's like oh [ __ ] that's
that's it he's like that's who he is he
like he a real like
not dinosaur you know how to serve he
was like he old and not nothing like
that
he just was like it's like a a myth
until you meet him
and i i lo bro the uh what's that the
what the public enemy mixtape
oh i remember that one green lantern was
a dj right yeah i got it yeah i did that
mixtape yeah i learned
i sold i sold that mixtape at the swap
meeting
i learned how to remember that's how i
got my name bootleg bootlegging
everybody [ __ ]
we was in a crib that's crazy we was in
a crib
and we was like i had learned how to
record right like i learned pro tools
just the basics of it
and he had this a freestyle of a public
enemy beat
and then i was just sitting in a crib
one day and i was like yo you should
call your [ __ ] like public enemy i said
we should make like
the um it was a picture that he we did
for like a state property photo shoot
and it was like it almost mimicked like
the uh what was that the public enemy
logo yeah i was like we should make it
like the logo but just have you
in the drink and he was like all right
we're gonna do it and then the reason
why we did the [ __ ] with green lantern
lanterns because we was listening to
championship
every day yo green lantern's mixtape
right but him and him and
kiss hadn't reconciled but bro we was
listening we listen that [ __ ] everyday
beings like yo
i gotta i gotta outdo kiss bro like he's
like yo this kiss [ __ ] is crazy we gotta
so we did we did that and i annard it
you know i'm a great
man and crib you meet him in the crib
bro what um cause that was uh
you know i don't know what it what it
was about beans i mean you know i i know
he had some issues with his voice
later on but like you know he had his
legal problems but it seems like
[ __ ] just kind of hit a wall for beanie
yeah um
what do you think happened to like his
career i think that the rockefeller
split up
i think well i'll say
i'll say um honestly bro and beans like
he'll respect this because like i love
him bro like i'm muslim i took my
shahada in his living room like that's
how close we are
we might not see each other all the time
but that's my brother for life i
say from my perspective is that he never
really took the time to learn the
business
now he was a great asset to the business
but as far as like
i always had this thing in my mind where
i felt like when jay
said he got rid was going to get rid of
rockefeller he would have gave all the
philly
he loved him bro like i seen jay show
more favoritism to the philly dudes than
the brooklyn dude sometimes you know
what i mean
dude like bleak glass hey it felt that
way though from a fan's perspective it
felt
like jay was just he really loved like
the grittiness of the rap style
and how real it was in their perspective
but think about it everyone
i mean young young guns dropped out you
know freeway dropped out like you know
i think i just think that beans and then
i i don't want to just say he didn't
learn it i feel like you know
he didn't have i can't say he didn't
have the right person now cause it's
people that i know that was around him
but i again i was a kid at that time i
can't speak for how they was handling
business because i just
when when i wasn't supposed to be in the
room i walk out still to this day bro if
i if i came into your studio and you was
having a conversation i won't even walk
in the room right
i know like if you tell if you give me
the if i if it's permissible for me to
be there i'll be there but
i stay in my place so a lot of [ __ ] that
was going on
when certain conversations is being had
i walk out because it ain't my place to
be in there so i
you know man yeah i think what with
beans at least from a fans perspective
perspective it just kind of felt like he
didn't leave the streets all the way
alone didn't and that's another
to to to his detriment possibly this is
what i be saying about the streets man
it's like
we we you love the streets when you
growing up well when you when you young
and like if you live in that life but
when you get older but
i guarantee everybody and i got i got
homies that like
did 15 years in prison biggest gangster
in the jail biggest gangster in the
street and they like
man i'm not doing no like i made a
mistake
yeah i mean i can't change it but that
[ __ ] is a mistake bro
and and the marketing aspect of music
that involves the streets is it looks it
looks cool
it looks cool to you facing an
indictment and also it helps sell
records
it does but it does but i don't know man
that [ __ ] is music is a hard thing for
me to deal with sometimes because i be
feeling like sometimes that i'm
i'm a part of the [ __ ] that i don't
agree with a lot
because as much as i'm saying all of
this like righteous sound and [ __ ]
i still love songs about people killing
people of course you know i mean like
i just i don't know it's like like you
know what people could say oh you uh
what's
what's the word um contradicting
being contradicted or being a hypocrite
right yeah hypocritical [ __ ] yeah being
a hypocrite
i feel like that's almost a part of
being human because like you feel
different times
you feel different ways at different
times you don't always sometimes bro i
wake up and i want the world to end and
sometimes i want to save the world
you know i mean but it's just how i deal
with it especially being in the music
industry like you said you could totally
feel that like man like you know i don't
like the way this [ __ ] is going
but still enjoy yeah a record that like
the pop smoke [ __ ] bro that [ __ ] made me
not
want to sign no gangbanger ever again i
never
i mean i didn't sign pop smoke but the
guys that he would sign to like rico
beats
that's one of my closest in music like
and beyond music
that's my man like here producer but me
and rico we met at a time before i even
met east
and we was trying to like we just
befriended each other and we was trying
to figure out
what our thing was going to be and i had
got east he still was producing
he had got his job at def jam we signed
a few acts they didn't work [ __ ] was and
then when he found pop
it it felt like a win for me because
seeing him so happy and seeing him
now he buying jewelry every weekend it
was such a celebration and then like i
only i only met pop one time but like
i had a conversation with him in a dm
one time and like
um just seeing the trajectory he was on
and he saluted me for getting the job at
asylum he like yo big bro like that's
amazing because he told me he used to
watch everyday struggle
he's like that's dope and it's that
third when that [ __ ] happened with him i
didn't even know the kid personally but
that [ __ ] happened i was like all right
what are we doing with
hey and to be fair he he didn't even get
killed over no gang [ __ ]
no but he got killed from that lifestyle
from that lifestyle so it's just like
oh what the [ __ ] are we doing what are
your thoughts yeah i mean what are your
thoughts about
th you know cause right now i just i
just spent the whole week out in new
york and i was shooting with um
dusty locain ross swish and ron suno um
but the the whole brooklyn gang ship is
crazy bro
i mean i'll tell you this when it come
to gangs brooklyn always been crazy
because like when when blood like when
blood popped off in new york
and caribbean popped off to new york
like first of all in new york
but these guys are getting like like if
you listen to these records like between
the
the woos and the
like from when i was when i was a
teenager bro like if you was a [ __ ] in
new york
you was tough because new york is a
blood like you're not like yeah yeah i
always think of new york is like raw i
just think of jim jones
like la la is a [ __ ] for sure new york
100 percent but the thing about the [ __ ]
in new york is
in prison bloods run everything ain't
the same with the [ __ ]
so the thing is is like for me on the
outside looking in
i see what i've seen in the 90s now like
in the 90s when gang [ __ ] popped off in
new york because it was coming from out
of jails
bloodshed came from out of jail when it
came to the streets it was bad because
people was adapting a jail mentality
before going to jail
so and and how they acted militant all
that [ __ ]
and then like seeing these kids now i
just be like yo bro
even when i think about these like when
when i be talking to dudes from from la
yeah
and like some of them like they they've
gangsters respect gangsters or rappers
but like they a lot of them that don't
jack like you know
bloods or crips over there i'd be like
yo that's your fault
like that's your kids bro like that's
that's offspring of you right of course
so it's like
seeing this [ __ ] bro it just a lot of it
rubs me the wrong way in brooklyn you
got
little kids getting hit with strays and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] just happened while we
were out there we were just in
in uh where where did it happen at
no no i was in brooklyn there was some
some some kid got hit there was a
shootout and some i think a little girl
yeah it got hit in the chest yeah right
outside a little boy yeah right outside
of a liquor store oh no bro it's that
but that's the thing it's like
i don't know because you know i i don't
i don't sit on like i'm born in 82
my generation be acting like we we sit
on this this pedestal where we had
everything right when we didn't
you know of course we did there which is
not social media of course it was not
social media but it's like
even the rationalization of like why
things were done it still don't make no
sense but it's like now it's like
it's even i think it's even worse now
because it's like
the name recognition amongst your peers
i got a 14 i got a 19 year old daughter
i got a 14 year old son
so it's like i'll be telling my son all
the time bro like i got a friend that
went to jail for attempted murder and he
just was telling me like wayne
i belong to myself for the first time he
just got off the papers and he like
i just i belong to myself for the first
time how crazy is that and i'm telling
my son i'm like yo do you hit it i say
bro
i tell my son like yo he shot somebody
when he was 18. and he just
and he's now finally free of the system
he's 40. bro
i'm like you don't that's not a pet you
used to get because his friends
yo bro my son certain kids that was on
his basketball au team
i didn't see any instagrams they'd be
carrying hammers and [ __ ] i'm like this
is crazy
[ __ ] and i don't even know why but i
know that a lot it plays into the music
in the lifestyle
and it's a lot of misinformation that
that spread i mean it's a lot of
misinformation i just be trying to do my
part
because i feel like you change the world
by changing one person's perspective hey
what up man
how to interrupt the bullet cab podcast
to tell you about our good friends
at odd socks all yo shout out to them
for
sponsoring the podcast but also we're
being such a fire company
and they just introduced their draws
that's right odd socks now got your
boxer briefs
on deck some tapatio joints and then of
course they got the best socks in the
game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
they got all the licenses breaking bad
mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddssocksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 at checkout and thank me later
is that something that you still kind of
carry with you as far as like the type
of artist you look to
look to sign because you said like after
pop had died you kind of were like i
don't want to
i can't but i love authenticity you also
want to do your job
i want to do my job but that's the tough
thing about being in the music you got
to do it all
yeah you got to like now at the same
time like from a business standpoint
the problem with business man business
ain't got nothing to do with feelings or
morals
has nothing to do with morals it has
nothing to do with feelings
because the same like that's why people
that be vegan be tweaking out about
chick-fil-a you feel me
because they their feelings and their
morals is in it yeah but they talking
about life
yeah some people don't think like that
but i feel like
rap is almost like a [ __ ]
slaughterhouse yeah it's crazy it is bro
it is because it's like i'll just be on
some [ __ ] like this like i'll be trying
to tell every
young artist i know me in the street
i'll be like yo listen bro like you
don't wanna go down that path bro
like even with beans when he got the
the shot that he um took that he lost
his voice
it wasn't even intended for him were you
around at that time i wasn't around him
at that time i mean we always i always
i always speak to him i speak to him
once a year at least right
but like i wasn't around him at that
time i'm also like younger than him so
like i mean he did
i didn't really have too much influence
on telling him what to do of course but
at the same time it's like
that wasn't even intended for him but
you see how [ __ ] happens
just being around that [ __ ] you never
know you can wake up you could wake up
today and it could be
you got to what you got to watch you got
to watch the the you got to watch what
you put out in this world bro
you got to watch what you put out in
this world that's a fact um
were you around during the kiss beanie
[ __ ] yeah yeah
the craziest [ __ ] is i always i mean
listen oh wow
i always i've talked to kiss about i've
talked to beanie about it and i always
say that that's probably the closest
back and forth because i depending on
where someone's from or who you ask or
who they're
i thought both of them won i thought
that we was going to die or we was going
to kill one of them i swear to god
because at the end because because at
that time
nobody was realer than beanie siegel let
me tell you something or the locks and
yonkers
about beans i love beans beans had us
train us the young guns
like i was you could basically say the
young guns was a gang within state
property bro
because they was from their own part of
town in philly they had us train bro
like like beans had us train
and i i used to really sit here like dog
jadakiss is one of my favorite rappers
like the locks bro
i don't know the man i would be without
the locks real [ __ ] i'm talking about we
all the streets is like
the words is in my dna of who i am as a
person so like
i used to be saying like we had we had a
we had a situation one time
with them though that happened we was in
um
you remember sunny she used to be on 97.
she's sunday yeah
like hg tv show yeah food and all that
but sunny had a birthday party
in brooklyn and and she had this
birthday party in brooklyn and jada was
hosting it
but she wanted the young guys at the
time we had cancer i won't stop so we
they was hot everybody was booking them
so she wanted us to do can't stop won't
stop
so we we had a show in va and
they was like by the time we get there
maybe kissing them and be out of there
so we get up to um we get the va i mean
we get to brooklyn from va
and um some philly dudes came and all
that [ __ ] or whatever
and pause it and uh
but um we get there and kiss somebody
from sunny's team came to our car was
like
hey katie kiss is still here could y'all
wait
until he leaves to come in like and he
was like yo
you don't want no problems so chris was
like yeah right and then chris sat there
and while we sitting there
like all these cars pull up and we see
like j hood get out
right oh [ __ ] styles was locked up at
the time but j-hood was there
a [ __ ] sheik and a bunch of dudes
right
so chris was like [ __ ] that we going in
there right
so they they go into the um
they go into the club they all walking
out with kiss
and uh chris christie manager was like
yo don't say nothing like don't say none
of them let them go ahead
yo they came outside and we were on the
line waiting to get searched
i don't know who it was but one of them
was like man [ __ ] all that d-block [ __ ]
what y'all [ __ ] want to do right
so that we get into the spec going back
and forth and then like
chris is standing there he gets searched
and like j hood
him and j hood is like saying [ __ ] to
each other and all that right this ain't
no social media nobody's seen this
happen
we get in the room we get into the
studio
and we get in there i don't know what
this dude from philly
who he was i seen him one time that day
i never seen him again
it was all of us in the room he said it
was like 15 of us in the room he said
yo who in here ain't bringing a burner
like four four or five people raised in
here he said i gotta burn it for
everybody who ain't bring one
he's bro i swear i thought he was gonna
die that night man he like yo
when we come outside we're not letting
nothing we
going all the way right i'm like what
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like all right did he give you a
burner i'm not going to say if he would
he gave me or he didn't
okay okay but um
we walk outside i think by that time
they had left
and then we go to baseline we have fun
that was it but like
damn bro i thought like we had a couple
yeah we had a couple
like little run the crazy thing about
that is like i didn't know i didn't know
jdks at the time janet kissed my man i
love kids of course
his son j1 that's my man i love him chic
all of them bro like
styles ironically when styles and
styles came home who called my phone i
think green lantern
called my phone and st styles on the
phone
he's like y'all got stylus p on the
phone and he like oh um he want to talk
to mac
and i put them on the phone they spoke
on my phone you know i mean and then
from there
years later me and styles we built our
brotherhood i love styles i love his
wife his son
yeah i mean like it's just crazy how
life works out but yeah it's a few times
bro but
i always think back to that time that
jada went to the the power show in
philly like the the big summer jam or
whatever way
yeah we did that we did that before j j
and i was the day [ __ ]
nobody did the same thing at hot 97
summer jam in new york
we did it at powerhouse okay okay so the
thing was we did
kiss was doing powerhouse in philly in
philly yeah
nobody knew beans was dead beans put on
a halloween mask
and he walked out on the stage and when
he was this at the same show
not the not not the one you talking
about he dissed him okay this is years
later
okay okay that happened in like oh two
this happened in like oh
five when o5 when beans came home okay
we do powerhouse and kiss that's what
i'm saying
people be thinking that jay took
everything from them but like jay did i
declare war after that when he brought
out knives okay yeah
so when he beans it was on halloween we
came out
beans he opened up his jacket and
everybody's in the sp chain and he took
the mask off and then they did reservoir
dogs
that's the first time that they had done
something together this is before jay
and nas reconciled this [ __ ]
so that was when they reconciled their
[ __ ] that's when they reconciled they
[ __ ]
but they had talked pride they
reconciled this [ __ ] when when beans had
um
came home do you remember like uh
man just that back and forth just bars
wise was so crazy
like those two freestyles were so crazy
like no but you don't remember all the
ones in between
no i just remember the two big ones
because i mean as i was on napster
downloading that [ __ ]
when he said when when beams is like he
said this cat still lives in his mother
house
and my basement bigger than his mother
house and i ain't talking about
my mother house or my brother house i'm
talking about the other house you ain't
never hear that nah
wrong now they was going crazy they was
growing
my favorite this and all of that was
styles on wait a minute
yeah i feel like like at that time
unless mlp had gotten into a beef with
somebody it was like probably the two
craziest like
people you would think where someone's
someone's gonna die yeah i know i i
really bro i was in
it's like it's like it's like being on a
battlefield almost like i don't know
what it is to be on a battlefield in war
but i know bro like we came into a lot
of clubs like
work i i love state property but [ __ ]
all y'all because y'all put my life in
danger bad times
i love all of them though but bro
working with them was dangerous bro
what was the original like origin of
their issue who
stay property of yeah of kissing beanie
i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know i have no idea bro
i have no idea i just knew that
whatever whatever when i worked at when
i worked with beans in them whatever
they was with you better be with that
whatever he owned you better be on that
tool you ain't you can't be around us if
you ain't so crazy too because
talking to damage he was always like
dude everyone's favorite rapper that's
not beanie siegel
from philly and that heir was kiss
absolutely he was like he was like the
biggest dude in philly like
absolutely
i would not call him a guy i'll use that
term with people with men but like
he was like yeah bro he was
i'll just say everybody that come from
that era bro jadakiss means a lot to us
if you was born in the 80s and you grew
up in the 90s bro
the whole lox though bro like the lox
man like like
my tattoo on my neck it stands for
respect over money style said that [ __ ]
in the freestyle that's why i tattoo
that [ __ ] on my neck
i live by their words bro because you
know what it was the locks for me was
this it's like
i'm coming outside i don't have the
relationship with my father
that i should have and i'm
going to school and coming home and
trying to navigate life as a teenager in
the 90s when the streets is crazy
i listened to the locks all day they
teaching me about honor and code and all
that [ __ ]
aside from what i'm learning with my
homies you know what i'm saying like
that
they they taught me honor and cold like
their music so they mean everything to
us
like however houston people feel for
[ __ ] um
one being pimp c for ugk yeah that's how
new york if you was born at that time
that's how we feel about the locks
locks is on though that's the highest
and i love wu-tang clan to death but
they're not the same for me as the locks
and i and
yeah i love the lives yeah the locks
definitely had more uh
i feel like practical life lessons
absolutely man
absolutely and their music um we were
talking earlier you we were talking
about our love for lupe
yeah i was talking about like my
favorite rappers which is different than
the greatest rappers list
yeah and my favorite rapper list always
pisses people off but you were like yo i
had lupe in my life who
was in my top five for a minute at some
point in time like who else is in your
top five
it always changes like right now who's
your top five favorite rappers right
or favorite right now this is it right
now the best right now just right now
like that you actually [ __ ] with not not
like that i actually [ __ ] with like
all right so look i'll be taking like i
ain't going fun bro
i never met drake and we we ain't the
best of friends drake might not like me
too much but whatever
drake the best you the best right now
rapper that's fair after that
huh [ __ ] rapper
i i got to put i put a little baby in
there
i put a baby gotta give little babies
put a little baby in there
um and this is the first time i've ever
done like a current drink because my top
five is always my top five all the time
but i put like hmm
rapper see i don't know where to put him
at but
i got to put conway in there conway is
my favorite guy in griselda and i love
all three yeah but not convinced
there's something about conway's ability
to convey pain on songs that like
it's conway you know i love about conway
conway
he knows how to flow he knows how to
like
he got punched lines he got me he got he
got it all man he got it all but
and benny but i feel like and he's right
there there's certain verses that benny
got that's just like no benny's
like guys don't bleed that's yo that
verse on that [ __ ] listen
benny is is in like god level m.c as
well they're both
jedis yeah they both jedi's yes see i
don't so i don't have like like what i'm
saying like i don't have a ranking
of like rappers right now because it's
like all right what about the all-time
list do you say that that's pretty
consistent
yeah this is your favorite yeah not like
j
old time biggie
uh j biggie nash
wayne and kendrick
thank you thank you for the kendrick
love yeah but i i ain't gonna lie i'm
i'm
i'm boycotting kendrick cause he hasn't
put out music yeah let me tell you
something
you can't you can't imagine the amount
of [ __ ] what i do with academics brother
amount of arguments i have people about
kendrick
i have screaming matches about kendrick
lamar and lebron james all the [ __ ]
time
but kendrick wrote like i i just i love
ken especially you being in new york
i bet you you butt heads with hella
people about kendrick i feel like not
really
not just because the thing about new
york is see
you got wayne over kendrick hell yeah
really yeah bro wayne
yo this is the thing man it's like and
i'm my thing is
kendrick's never missed wayne's missed a
lot
missing is all subjective right not
really
but but wayne's got some black eyes on
his face he's got
he does but he's got classes but so do
tupac you know i got a lot of a lot of
misses
yeah yeah it's a lot which is why which
is why tupac's not in my top he's he's
he's in my top 10-ish but but like i got
um
i kind of put wayne and tupac in the
same tier nah
you put way better rapper than tupac
he's a way better rapper i don't it is
people that probably send me death
threats for that i don't give a [ __ ]
yo listen i've someone threa i said
tupac was overrated as an mc
i didn't say his music was overrated i'm
a huge poc fan yeah huge i had posters
of them on my walls
all of us did but i said that [ __ ] i
forget what interview it was
and the [ __ ] was dming my wife
threatening to kill her bro
dog she had to make her page private so
so so look so
people don't play about tupac now people
don't play about tupac but i love tupac
too but at the same time it's like
i stack people get and they feelings
about pop
right in there it's two people pock and
kobe you can't say nothing about because
people
hello kobe is one of my favorite but i'm
just saying like you know kobe fans
are crazy people no i don't know they're
not because i'm i'm one of them people
you're one of the people okay okay yeah
i want to i'm i'm definitely not bro
i'm definitely i'm definitely one of
them people that was buying kobe's
when they was on sale when nobody was
wearing them before nobody was wearing
them yeah i was one
i actually got a pair of elite kobe's
like that because the dude at house of
hoops is like
yo you're the only person that haven't
seen body shits and wearing hair you
could get them and it was only like ten
pairs
but yeah the tupac tupac fans are very
emotional they are
but like i feel like but poc is a
great artist but see
all time it's hard to do all the time
because i got to put kanye i don't go
[ __ ] if he ain't ready
but kanye's in a class of michael
jackson yes i don't think that tupac's
in the classroom
i think kanye is in class let me ask you
if you agree with this i think kanye has
the best discography
in hip-hop history [ __ ]
who's got a better discussion yes who's
got a better discography
i think the only miss was jesus's king
and i mean yeah he had some jesus king
was trash
please like that juice for sure he could
have went he could have went like od
traps like trapped soul meets gospel and
that have been hard
i ran through that album once and never
touched it again kanye fan
how you mess up a clip song we ain't
gonna go there all right so look so
yeah i ain't gonna find he might kaia
got it bro who else got i mean i think
i think i think the closest is kendrick
because kendrick has no but kendrick
don't have the uh a mouse
bro kendrick don't have the mountain
take out classics
take away classics and ghost faces up
there too
take out classics take out the classic
word games got a nice discography
game is one of the best rappers that
ever [ __ ] if i wanted somebody to rap
for 24 hours straight because i was
trying to win a prize i'll go get games
game rap all day about anything like but
i i love gabe what
bro and i i can't run away from this bro
we gotta stop playing with drake bro see
nah bro i'm gonna keep it listen wait
wait wait and it's hard for me it took
me a long time because to admit to this
it's hard to listen it's hard to put
as a jay-z fan yeah it's hard to put
anybody on the same level as jay-z
drake's up there i equate drake
to the jay-z [ __ ] like this might to me
michael jordan the greatest
person ever touched basketball right but
steph stephen stephen curry is the
greatest person to ever shoot a
basketball that's 199
right that's how i equate the drake
whole [ __ ] because it's like and not
that i'm drake's the greatest hit maker
ever
but this is what i'm saying but but at
the same time i don't think anyone can
perform more hits in a row than drake
you know it's the realest [ __ ] you
haven't been on a drug show
of course i only been to one and i'm
kind of a drake hater low-key
like historically i've never been a
hater i may not agree with his actions
i'll say that right i don't hate him
i wouldn't say a hater but i love him as
an artist i don't know him i just don't
um
but bro i went to the summer 16 [ __ ]
i went to summer 16 it was him and in
the future yep i remember that
bro and madison square garden like the
[ __ ] floating in there yeah
the that wasn't the ferrari it was like
some like balls
bro i was dead i was in the riser right
everybody's
everybody industries in the riser i was
standing next to charlemagne and me and
charlemagne was like
damn right then he did this [ __ ] like
you know you know how
jay used to do this [ __ ] he used to be
like he played songs and cut him off
play someone's coming off yeah
brother so i was waiting for drake to do
worse behavior i'm like oh no oh you
remember
he did that during that show he's like
ah it was like i couldn't believe it
no i couldn't believe it i swear to god
yo he did and that was
i was waiting for worse behavior yo he
put on worse behavior and i'm and
the great thing about being in a rise is
you can see everything right right right
and i was looking he played that [ __ ]
for 15 seconds he's like not [ __ ] i
turn that [ __ ] off i was like what
yeah and and i can't remember which song
he played after that but
i was like nah bro well that's like on
the uh the tour he did with migos where
he was running across the [ __ ]
basketball
basketball push it he was just right he
just did quick features
like 10 in a row and like was like i
just want to remind y'all like oh yeah
it was all but that's what i'm saying i
think like the thing is like all right
look
yeah if you a j fan and you
i'm a biggie fan j fan we also didn't
mention jay's best
discography in hip-hop history which is
crazy he's he's no but he does
he's probably him and kanye for being
fair
or drake but i put kind of gets a slight
edge just because of producing he gets a
slight edge
right i agree but yeah jay right like
because i was having his debate with
academics and he was telling my hits and
he was like
where i'm from is not a hit i'm like
how's not a hit right i'm like because
bro see you and i understand how he
could say that but
but the reason why he says that is
because you in the era with 50 cent have
[ __ ] up everything with the sales [ __ ]
right right well y'all equate
how you interpret music based on what it
sells so when where
i didn't know what gold the platinum
even meant at all
i didn't know that it meant selling a
million when i was a kid like think
about [ __ ]
dark and hell is hot bro i didn't know
you know dark
fleshing my flesh blood on my blood so
387 000 records the first week and did
not have a single or a video
i was both in the same year both in the
same that's what i'm saying it's like
so i didn't know nothing about the sales
[ __ ] but people like
axe [ __ ] was like billboard i'm like
so you let these people have no
face their system determined what's the
best [ __ ] ever
nah like you know what i mean because
i'm like yo
like if jay had to go hit for hit with
somebody he could go all day but i but
one thing i said
but drake nobody can go here with drake
the problem with drake is drake
start pulling them [ __ ] from half court
like steph
you're gonna start pulling that [ __ ]
from half court yeah and i still put i
still
have in my book j over drake of course
of course but he's
i can't i think with drake i think i
think drake
is kind of like you said how steph curry
kind of came through and it's just like
not fair with
the game he changed the way the game's
played the change i think drake
has some things you could say about him
obviously the
the writing [ __ ] you know yeah i also
look at the way he responded to that and
kind of like low-key had meek's career
in a little chokehold for a while but
you know like but then i look at
drake and the pusher thing and how i was
so disappointed that drake never replied
to push his [ __ ] freestyle
bro i ain't gonna lotto it's like it was
like
he was in a very tough position but i
always used to say you know what i
always just say about drake i used to
before him and push i had his issues i
used to always say like
he needed to do a takeover just attack
everybody he needed to just
make a record i always wanted drake to
make kind of like kendrick's control
verse
but he didn't kendrick didn't attack
people right but he definitely he caught
everybody
he was being nice yeah it was it was a
polite hey guys i'm better than y'all
but but i really feel like
i don't know kendrick but i really feel
like kendrick believed that nobody could
[ __ ] with him
i think that's still nobody i i don't i
feel like rapping
but at the same time that's what i'm
saying it's like
when you start getting into bars and
quotables and hip-hop is not just based
on
that it's based on everything it's based
on everything it's based on your
presence and all that and like
it's like now bro it's like the nba i'd
be like yo they might as well just make
the nba
the christmas game the all-star game in
the playoffs because nobody plays no
more
i know y'all got injuries and [ __ ] but
nobody don't [ __ ] play this [ __ ] is
crazy
and it's like that's how i'm feeling
about hip-hop now it's like people don't
play as much as they used to it's like
uh we growing up after
we get a wu tang album and then we get
all these albums in between and then
another we hang out and then more albums
in between and then another
thing they they still holding their
space locks
they did the same [ __ ] right lock's
album jadakiss styles
chic then d block compilation right jada
kiss again and styles and sheik right
they kept doing they kept doing it all
like [ __ ] the dog pound bro
snooping them like snoop after he
brought the dog pound he brought the i
had i bought that inside his album yeah
i
mean
he said he's almost fired yeah he saw
alex had just like child trading yeah
sleeping was a goldilocky training they
had drinks on there you know what i'm
saying but i bought that eastside as i'm
like
they kept it consistent because it's
consistent now it's like the incas you
want to be
incon like you consistent when you drop
but you drop
it's like a solar eclipse you know what
i mean now it's like we got to wait so
long and
yeah but that's the only thing with like
i i hope this next kendrick album is
crazy
i think but that's the pr though it's
it's a gift and a curse because it's
like
for me i don't i'm not expecting like i
don't think that kendrick can outdo
himself i just think that every time he
does something that hasn't been done
he doesn't out like i don't feel like
good cat mad city
good kid matthew is one of the greatest
albums of all time facts or
in any genre i agree but like when you
get to
to pimple butterfly i can't compare the
two because they're he he was doing
something totally different on a
butterfly in the way but he did it on a
high level yeah then damn
damn a classic album i don't give a [ __ ]
what nobody say i think i mean i think
all three kendrick albums are classics
and let's not section 80 let's act like
that was sweet section 80 was officially
an album as well
so you couldn't get that you had to buy
that on itunes and like i said like i
don't
with these artists it's like we want to
be entertained so we don't know
like i'm sitting in the stool for 100
hours like oh [ __ ]
like trying a bunch of [ __ ] and saying i
don't know if i'm
like lauren hill bro it was a reason why
she only made one album she could never
do that [ __ ] again
you can never do it again crazy and that
piece of art though is
one of the greatest of all time but if
that's the art that we have to accept
for and that's what we have
i'm cool with that do you think drake i
think everyone would say that take care
is a classic not everyone because i i
personally don't think he's got an
undeniable classic
yeah take care not take his undeniable
classic bro yeah i'm saying justin
i feel like it's undeniable no no no no
no no i think that i'm gonna talk about
this
but listen but listen like i think that
there's not a consensus amongst everyone
that that's a classic
i think that i think that i would say
it's a classic
personally but i don't think it's a
consensus it's a critically acclaimed
class
right like i feel like there's albums
like nobody's ever going to tell you get
rich or die trying isn't a classic
like anybody who you respect in hip-hop
would never ever say
but i tell you why though it's our
standard
we're from the same i'm only a couple
years older than you but we're from the
same era of when we learned this idea of
what a classic was
and then we think about our classics i
used to think like if you can't make
something the same as the infamous it's
not a classic
if you can't make the same as reasonable
doubt it's not classic and that's
content
it's the subject matter it's the singles
and all of that
only built for cuban links music has
changed but i think
since since drake's come out there's
been classic albums that have came out
yeah so even though it's like two
records on there it's like what my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy good
commands
i mean we just talked about kendricks
right so
it's other people records on there like
freestyles but so far gone bro
so far going is a classic body of work
i mean undeniable that's undeniable i
think that when drake came out with the
singing [ __ ]
everybody was like oh he saw what he did
so he that so they would
because hip-hop was in a weird-ass space
right right so it's like
they they say he not hip-hop like people
consider drake
like you still got a a army of like a
[ __ ]
organization an army of people that
still say well drake's not hip-hop
because he sings
right and i just look at it
i i didn't was it in that crowd but i
used to look at it like
well he need to just make a whole album
rapping but he doesn't
because it'd be nice though why though
but because look
hey russ did that chomp ep and i was
like this is great it shuts some people
up
yeah but i feel like russ got more to
prove than drake definitely
yeah yeah yeah bro anybody who meet
russ if you never knew who he was like
if i took the rest of my hood somebody's
people
i wouldn't say i just mean like if no
one knew who he was they'd be like why
you got this white boy with long hair
yeah but then you have right he can grab
his ass off but that's what i'm saying
is like
he got more approved than drake you're
saying drake doesn't have to do that
because he's already got
i feel like i feel like for the people
who
feel like he has he's never going to
make them happy
they're never yeah yeah never be happy
that's fair because like honestly
even with me and cause me and academics
have had a lot of drake debates
especially with the whole [ __ ] and all
of that
and like i had to start looking i i took
a lot of my
like i love drake as an artist like i've
listened to every one of his
albums all of them i mean the only one i
don't like is uh what's the first one
thank me later i don't like that album
it had like four drinks on it
i wasn't crazy about more life more yeah
i wasn't crazy about
more life never but like take me later
had some [ __ ] but i hate i hate the fact
that if you're reading this too late is
oh no that's a mixtape no it's not it's
a [ __ ] album i
i can't enjoy that album the way
everyone else does because because
because of me
yeah but at the same road but but that
album is like some of his best music i
agree
especially just rapping yeah we just
don't know who wrote it
yeah i'm saying that i know but i ain't
gonna find nowadays the people there
everybody writing for them i don't i got
over that bro i had to get over it it's
tough
i had to get over it because bro it's a
different era now the people when you be
come on bro you be in the studio well
also you know how it is because you
you're in studio sessions and you
realize everyone gets help
everybody whether it's the homie in the
corner who's like feed you a line
because but we but we come from that era
of like if you was in this if you was in
the lunchroom and you think kendrick's
getting help
i don't know i don't know man i don't
think i don't know bro i'm gonna keep it
100
i'm not i would i wouldn't say he is it
would probably i would probably shut the
thug 10 on the inside like you know what
i mean yeah my argument because i'm glad
you say kendrick's in your top five
because i always tell people who have
biggie in their top five as well i'm
like look
biggie deserves to be in that
conversation but while he
we got two albums from him and they were
both classics
yeah kendrick we've got if you i can
argue section 80 is a classic but let's
say take a second 83 let's
he's got three undeniable he's not
missed he has a miss
so if you're gonna put biggie in that
conversation off of two albums you gotta
put kendrick in that conversation with
the greatest all time
yeah absolutely but see the thing is is
like
bro we we all realize how great people
are when they're gone
you know what i'm saying like we all
realize how great people are when
they're going it's like
you look at dmx right and i wouldn't be
mad if somebody had dmx as their number
one on a top five of course
when i was a kid for two years as a
child yeah probably three years dmx was
my favorite rapper in the world
i'm not even gonna lie and admit this to
you heart the the hard knock life tour
that backstage movie when i was there
we probably stayed for two of jay-z's
songs and then went home
bro it was we were there to see dmx
i did not understand for the life of me
why dmx was going on before jay-z
and at that time that was volume two
whole yeah he had them he had them
records
it was it was they thought he had them
record right um that's like i remember
jay came out he had the car on stage and
i was like
my cousin was like hey you want to go
home and beat the traffic and i was like
we already saw dmx
method man and redmond were just flying
through the [ __ ] sky yeah let's go
home
that's like bro like uh who i like um
that's like i don't give a [ __ ] nobody
say like future in my top ten
i don't even know what my top ten is but
future in it really i swear to god bro
i don't care what nobody say ain't no
dick riding none of that i love future i
know i love
i love future but i want i mean i think
for what he does he's the greatest of
all time i don't know if there's a
better club
like club rapper but see that's the
thing i don't even want to put him in
club rapper because
that's people always equate future to
just a club rapper
future his music is street [ __ ] so he's
got some most
harmonic [ __ ] bro i know but i'm talking
about he got songs with like
one of my favorite songs from future is
made myself like streets calling
that mixtape streets calling got mad
future [ __ ] on it where he rapping and
people
never got onto that because they just
got on a [ __ ] at the same damn time
and it was just
held onto that and never listened to
[ __ ] if you got the tolerance or the
time
to listen to future can he [ __ ] with
kendrick as a rapper no
not saying that by no means but if you
listen to what he's saying
and you like rap you'll be like oh he
got some [ __ ] in there same as thug i
feel the same way about though
i think i put i low-key put thug above
future oh you willing
no no no no i i'll take future's catalog
tell
catalogs
i just think that i just think young
thug uh
has i mean future's a very versatile
artist but i feel like i've heard
thug like some of his inflections and
[ __ ] i just don't know if anyone else
can pull off
some of the [ __ ] young thug does they
can't people can do it
people can do a cheap future
impersonation it's to me oh no
they can't bro they can't to me thug is
like so
the way he changes he'll really just be
the beats for road it don't
future like listen to ganglion and like
i said i'm not saying listen to gang
land
and say this verse is not better than
conway's
i've been waiting for someone to put
future up in the verses too i'm like man
who oh no
i might want to play with him i don't
know who i don't know who could bro
people
even you seen when they was making that
rumor about travis scott and then the
meme started oh yeah travis to get
washed and i love travis but not against
future
future bro now travis and young thug
would be good
that would be a good one no travis
travis travis got special but future bro
they can't [ __ ] a future bro so you got
them top 10 all the time oh yeah i got
them top ten on the side
cause i co for my rapture but that's
what i'm saying personal favorites
that's your favorite like like in your
favorites not necessarily like who you
think is the greatest of all time yeah
yeah it's not what i think is the
greatest audience it's your favorite
yeah he's my
he's one of my favorite artists ever but
so is ludacris i love it so it's ti
man luna chris so his young buck would
have loved albums oh young bucks
first two second album [ __ ] the what the
world was one of the most slept on
albums ever made god block the world is
[ __ ] it was after how many had the
prices on my head record was that on the
first hour personally has the first
house yeah but the second album had some
[ __ ] no one um no one ever talks about
buck the world
bro broke the world it's hard bro that
was one that's probably one of the
saddest
things in hip-hop for me was that young
buck never really kind of
like he should have kept going man luda
was that dude though
i'm so glad to hear luda on that new
record with conway and jed that [ __ ] was
yeah and he held his own nah absolutely
absolutely i mean ludic bro
i think luda is a mess like people don't
be knowing it
it's like i equate luda like ice cube
bro he's the same thing as ice cubes
like when my son seen straight out of
compton he was like
that's ice cube like he couldn't believe
it he was like that's like you guys
friday yeah we did that friday all the
i'm like yeah all about the benjamin
yeah that's ice cube like they don't but
i would i would have took the same route
luda did i mean but luda people act like
man
luda when he did um what's the [ __ ] that
ron brown did for him
blow it out your ass like thumb joints
looted first album
yeah i look back for the first time more
than mouth red light district hasn't
been on it what's the drink chicken um
oh yeah uh chicken beef chicken and beer
mm-hmm
bro he hits hits hits hits hits
and he can rap um with you what's so
this new podcast
is is is just one of the new things that
you have coming yeah it's just one of
the new things
i i don't i don't really talk about like
ink is dry on certain [ __ ] but i don't i
i let i let the work speak for
itself you know um i do got some some
[ __ ] coming
i'm just i'm i'm still learning bro like
you know the the media career has given
me a new
life and i'm only three years in i'm set
i'm
on my music [ __ ] i'm 20 in right i mean
i started at
[ __ ] 18. so i'm 20 in i'm 38
not consistent but i'm still like making
up for the last time i had
so i'm learning new [ __ ] i'm working
with new people i'm
i got different perspectives i'm
building new things new ideas i'm
building a merch line for my um
company triangle offense which was you
know my label that's what dave wasanto
as a on the management client but i
changed it to not just
management and production company to an
aspirational inspirational
lifestyle brand because like i want to
inspire you know i mean
i want to aspire to inspire like it's
it's my duty
for me to make people feel like they can
that's why i started my podcast i look i
think what's dope about your podcast
is it's kind of needed in this space i
think we get a lot of that from like
wallows instagram
yeah somebody's interested i love you
real quick i'll tell you about that you
know how many times wallow cursed me out
about doing a podcast bro while
wallow was on my ass bro i'll tell you
one time wallow
um and of course i met him through
social media but we got a lot of mutual
friends in philly a lot of mutual
friends
and wallow called me one day and was
like uyno i'm telling you right now bro
you're leaving so much money on the
table
and he like not just the money but bro
he like it's all these different things
that you could do once you start
and he was telling me but wild talk fast
and he
he gave me one call like every couple
months and he left me with that and i
was like
uh how do i do it and i was scared to do
it i'm not gonna lie bro i'm not gonna
act like i was like i'm just this uh
invincible person that
has no flaws and has no um what's that
insecurities about [ __ ] like
are they gonna like it do they like me
does everybody just like academics on
the show and don't [ __ ] with me at all i
know he has his fan base but i never
built mine
and then i was like you know what [ __ ]
it i'm gonna just jump off this diving
board and see what happens and we've
been doing
you know hear me out with wayno is every
thursday i'm saying
uh instagram is hear me abueno it's uh
the twitter is hearing me out i mean
hear me wayno
um and we're just gonna go i mean we're
gonna go and i'm gonna have like i will
have
i would love to have you on on the
podcast but when you do it's not gonna
be so much centered around music i might
just bro you're a father like you know
what i mean we might just talking talk
[ __ ] about
the things that our kids is into how you
feel about this issue versus
what i'm saying i think it's that's
missing like and i think that like i
said
we get a lot of that from wallowing from
um
and from gilly and and and i i wish they
would do they i used to love
the podcast with no interviews yeah yeah
yeah and they've been killing the
internet
because they make people so comfortable
bro they i i tell them
this all the time like their interviews
are my favorite i mean obviously drink
champs is on a crazy run i love
nori bro like the nor
the cam and the pharrell interview were
like two of my favorite interviews ever
i hope i get to do a drink and i don't
even drink like that but i hope i get to
do a drink champs one day because like
nori when nori came to rockefeller
remember he was sounding rockefeller
yeah
yo nori was one of the funniest people
i've ever met in my life dog
oh my god because that was like uh he
that was like when it was like
rockefeller like
reggaeton like that no that was before
that that was before that
regular that was when dame had signed
him game is chained and all that and
then
he was already there basically he was
signed to death gym
and def jam wasn't really moving too
much and
rockefeller we had uh distro through def
jam so it was just like
all right we could take it on and you
know what i mean do whatever with him
and put the rockefeller brand around and
all that
and it's just like i was when i was
around nori i was 21.
so i don't forget nothing that happened
because these are like
this is [ __ ] nori you know what i
mean it's the greatest time of my life
being around this guy
it's mad stories i got with me being
around north he might not
remember nor he's a yeah nori is uh
like the sweetest dude but he's also
like when you think of like some of the
stories he's been involved with
you're like no worry one of the like i
always say him and fat joe are like some
of the biggest goons to ever
[ __ ] fat yeah fat joe fat joe was it
went to kindergarten with my sister
yeah i just oh man i've heard so many
like folklore stories about fat i used
to work with his dj dj chris john when i
was when i was on the radio in tampa but
he used to tell me the craziest
worst projects bro fat joke stories how
they would move was like some real
terrorist the name but the name is
called terror squad like
jesus like we don't take these brands
serious until they say smack somebody
head over
state property that that's property of
the state
beans was calling this [ __ ] criminal
records but i'm just saying look what
you manifest when you do that
yeah unfortunately unfortunately d-block
you know d-block
cell block like it's it's i get why
because it was authentic
to the to the artist and the person but
at the same time it's like now we're
getting older we're
not looking at it like that hey what was
the biggest time you ever kind of
disagreed with some academics did where
you kind of had to like you know
the six nine thing yeah did you guys
have off of the record conversations
about it yeah we had a mad conversation
about it but we had we had one
conversation we had one conversation
that got a little crazy they had to take
a lot of it out i was wild
on video yeah okay but that's only the
reason why
is because it's like it's certain
brothers and sisters that like
you know they attach themselves to the
you know that brotherhood and i know
them and
we're tight and like seeing
seeing how he was treating
that whole thing seeing how 69 was
treating that whole [ __ ]
i always felt that 69 could have been
like the most successful artist without
doing that
but also he was around a bunch of dudes
that didn't know business you know what
i'm saying like
these dudes is they they they serious
people in the street
that never been in they've been around
music but never had the ball in their
hand
so it's like i felt like yeah
he used them they used him but he used
them like it ain't one-sided
yes and the thing about it is bro it
ain't even about
i don't agree when it comes to like you
know i ain't in the street
right now i don't give a [ __ ] about who
snitch you know who i know why cause i
ain't in the street that ain't my
lifestyle
but like i've been in situations where i
had to stop talking to friends i grew up
with because they chose a certain life
when i was trying to live a certain life
so that rubs me a certain way i got
friends that did
15 some years because somebody told on
him you know i mean it's not even about
just that it's about the prevention it's
about not putting yourself in a
situation to do that so i would never
i'm not gonna tell no kid if he get
locked up where he or she should do
that's for them to decide what i'm gonna
tell you is how about
we get you more focused on things that
will not put you in a position to get
locked up that's what i'm about
being proactive not reactive because
once once a kid
goes to jail or a kid passes everybody's
all sad and everybody got
oh this down the third we need more
prevention and i felt like
with dude you know was doing whatever
was like just perpetually like he was
yeah a lot of a lot of people turned up
on the gang [ __ ] because
when they did it they heightened it on a
mainstream level and a lot of kids are
looking at it like
he ain't like that i'm really like that
so i'm really going to do it you know
what i'm saying and now they
they catching indictments and all that
so what does it bring for real like you
know i mean that [ __ ] don't bring
nothing but pain
facts that's crazy yeah i always thought
that like because because just kind of
who you are and and and you know even
just watching the show
on a regular basis like you can kind of
tell like the morals you stand on yeah
i just i just thought that there was
some some academic [ __ ] and again i was
i got a number of respect for academics
yeah
uh outside of the freddy gibbs [ __ ]
happened and him him bringing up fred's
kids and not so well because
of my brother but i respect like the
career he's built up but yeah i just
figured that there was a
had to be a few things where he was like
bro like is it well no it's
well hmm let me think it's different i
can't think of everything bro we did
yo you went i did probably 300 something
i was on every day stronger longer than
joe button was
that's facts so so i did 300 something
episodes of that [ __ ] so i can't
remember
everything bro i'm talking monday
through thursday
every morning at seven in the morning a
lot of that [ __ ] is a blur
and and some [ __ ] you can see and some
[ __ ] you won't but the thing about me is
it's like
it's a lot of [ __ ] that we didn't agree
on bro but but at the same time it's
like we knew that we came there to do a
job we came to
entertain i felt like you know for me i
was on that show for three years you
know what i'm saying for me to
i'm grateful to complex that's good
because
who got me on that show and i co-signed
it and that's what
spearheaded my media um career
and i've and like you it worked it ain't
like they brought you on
like and it was well the thing is bro is
that i sp i'm a sponge like i
if you could hit you hear me talk about
my rockefeller days i got in the room i
learned i sat around i played my part i
sat in the corner
i was the person yeah so i looked at it
from the perspective
of this it's like i got in there for all
the [ __ ] even with the [ __ ] that
means
it's a lot of conversations that i had
with aqua act told me how to handle
business in the media space
so when i did my deals he like yo make
sure you help yourself
make sure you he told me bro he
instilled something for me i'm grateful
for
that you know what i'm saying and him
and me you know it's like it's like
almost like the same [ __ ] you're saying
when she was like like me
bro i've known me since he was 16.
mm-hmm and i [ __ ] with act but meek my
i got real genuine love for me because i
knew him when he caught this when he
caught his shirt before he
i'm kind of glad the clubhouse thing
happened because it kind of i hate
clubhouse bro i haven't had clubhouse on
my phone for a while
i haven't used it in like five months
that's a wrap yeah it's over for me for
that but but
like it's just i love balance
i feel like you can't we can't have all
the things i can't have the morals that
i stand on and this down the third and
teach
and educate if i don't have examples of
other people
and not specifically act but other
people that be out here shackling the
[ __ ] fool
i'm saying so i could be able to show
examples like yo listen
i ain't gonna tell you what to do but if
you want to do it just
make sure you do it your way don't feel
the pressure it's feeling like you got
to be this person
what was the cr was there ever a crazy
moment where you guys had interviews at
complex
and things kind of got uh weird with the
artists
yg yg came in because that was right
after like
like six nine was going crazy on yg
and what the thing is is like i got a
rapport with them with ygnum you know i
mean like a [ __ ] would be more you know
i mean
yeah b is my guy brandon is my great you
push push it right like
i [ __ ] with a lot of his dudes you know
what i'm saying and like when i when i
every every room i walk into i'm being
myself saying so when i'm coming in
i speak to everybody i ain't just speak
the yg i came in there i said with up to
his homies before i saw him yeah what's
up
it's early in the morning how your
brothers doing y'all good flight was
cool all right cool
they came in so act came in
i mean usually the artists that like
don't
[ __ ] with they usually sit next to me
okay so
they usually sit next to me so why'd you
you know he's sad with me you know i
mean it was cool but like
you was waiting to see if he was gonna
play with him you know what i mean but
but
ultimately like why jesus he's a real
good guy bro like i went to uh one of
his brother
his brother's birthday party one time
met his his mom his pops and all
people be looking at these artists and
they just think that they these reckless
dudes because he chose a certain way of
life he's a good brother you feel me
so i wanted to ask you because you've
worked with you worked with dave early
on
and dave's one of my favorite artists
insane mc
yeah women love him right right killing
it on the acting
he's kind of like the full package but
for some reason he's never kind of
gone over the hump at being like a
commercial success
why do you think that is like in your
opinion for being someone who's been so
close to him
oh i i mean this is a record business
you gotta make records
i mean i feel like like dave has he has
all the qualities to make him
be over that but like i just feel like
because i still you know i tune in and
[ __ ] like me and dave don't
first and for like me and dave don't
have a bad rapport right i mean like it
was a point in time but we weren't
speaking
but regardless of that dave had reached
out to me when i lost my father
and because him and my father had their
own relationship and
he was he was very sincere his approach
and
i took dave to become muslim he's gonna
be my brother forever he's my brother
here in an afterlife so i love dave but
i always felt like dave
um i always i
for me my vision for him was to always
be bigger
i don't know what a vision that he had
for himself once i stopped working with
him
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
what transpired after that we went our
separate ways
but like i just feel like dave has an
insane ability
he's he's a dope rapper that's why i was
[ __ ] with him i mean yeah i mean look
and like
i just i i feel like he checks all the
boxes he checks all the body but i mean
you got to remember bro everybody's not
like everybody's not meant to be what we
want them to be
and you see that in sports before you
see it in music you know i mean like
that happens in sports all the time all
the time bro you know how many number
one picks i was living and dying by and
then like they end up not being shabazz
muhammad what the [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ] but you know they reclassified
him because he was old he's lying by his
age and all that [ __ ] yeah
yeah but like but but yeah even him like
when he's at ucla andrew wiggins
andrew [ __ ] what no andrew yo i swear
i wanted the sons to tank for wiggins
bro dante exum hey exum from he's from
australia
he's from australia but let me tell you
something bro it wasn't a person i
i won a hundred dollar bet off of um
andrew wiggins when he came to the
league because i was betting when he's
homies
he said that he went average 14 points i
was like i said he's gonna get he's 14
points off a fast break i think he's
gonna get eight points off a fast break
the kid's a freak athlete yeah like
you can't [ __ ] that package up but i
feel like he still has the ability
some people unlock it later on lebron
[ __ ] was instant melody
zach levine's unlocked it later on yeah
zach levine unlocked it later on you
know what i'm saying like
like donovan mitchell like that are you
are you a nick fan no i'm a lakers fan
oh really interesting that's convenient
no no it's not i mean second greatest
franchise of all time yeah but i stuck
through the tough times see
anybody who's like i was watching when
it was vladivac and eddie jones rick van
nexter
absolutely bro listen i used to tape the
remember these kids but i used to tape
the nba draft yeah
we couldn't go on instagram and just
resee it right right to tape that [ __ ] i
used to
remember when when uh nba live ain't
have the rookies
writes to write down every single rookie
and look at all their attributes and
create them on live and [ __ ] bro i was a
[ __ ] i'm a basketball fiend
i love my love for the for the lakers
came not
just from they didn't come from the
convenience of shaq and um
kobe it came from phil jackson that's
why i named my company triangle offense
right
right right because i started so you
were kind of a later laker fan then i
was but i was
i said i was a kid when i became like
before you were a laker fan were you a
nick fan
no i was a bulls fan yeah i was about i
mean but i was like i'm a sons fan i'm
from phoenix but
i use a [ __ ] oh that's tough no no
because as a kid it was michael jordan
michael jordan but that's what i'd be
telling people so it's like when you
meet a a kid that's eight years old
you'd be like
who's your favorite team it's the golden
state warriors when it was 73 and 9
because they're the best it's marketing
it's the best thing but like
i'm a laker fan bro laker fan do you
think
like like you know i'm so much of a lego
fan i was against lebron coming to the
lakers
at first you're one of those kobe guys
huh you have your side of the of the war
and it's kobe
i had a lot of lebron kobe arguments bro
look when you've had the lebron arc
i had almost fist fight arguments about
lebron kobe bro so it's like
when you say kobe is better than lebron
huh you're saying kobe is better than
lebron
i don't think he's a better athlete i'm
someone just better everybody
all-time all-time great conversation
you're putting kobe over lebron
all the time okay all right do you see
at least you're reasonable
um you're reasonable i'm not because
lebron bro like steve kerr said the
realest [ __ ] about lebron one time he's
like yo
do you know how hard it is to get to the
finals he like even if he's lost like
like even if he's low you know how hard
it is to get it's people that see in the
finals on the bench one time and didn't
have a career after that i always tell
people like
the year he went it was it oh five and
then
they had seven was it 007 when eric snow
was the point guard
that's the second worst team to ai's
team
yeah ai's team was rough hey by the way
both both teams had eric snow
and aaron mckee i think probably yeah
but like
so and he went through the pistons
in the eastern conference finals they
wasn't yeah they were still the pistons
though
come on we're not going to do the
michael jordan they was the pistons he
went to
no no it was the pistons that beat the
lakers who had carl malone and gary
payton it was i know but
as a rook there's a lot of factors why
that championship the way today the
thing i will say about lebron is lebron
has the greatest championship i've ever
seen i agree 2016.
and that was the greatest and i could
have went to that [ __ ] bro really
i could have went to a game we was on
tour fred you remember that
he was on tour i've known rich paul
since like 2002
2003 i've known response right i've
never met lebron in my life though
that's a crazy thing
but i've no response from matt yeah so
some little girl we end up we we on we
we're not managing dave we're on tour
and we're in
we in cleveland and we got a show in
columbus the next day
and this little girl she keeps looking
or whatever and then rich paul walks in
i'm like oh [ __ ] rich was good nobody
knew what rich looked like
at that time like that unless you really
really right right right so i chopped it
up a rich you know
he's like yo that's my daughter he's
like yo can she take a picture with dave
i'm like yeah
they take a picture so he like yo what
y'all doing tonight i'm like yo we about
to go to columbus we got a show he's
like man come to the game i think
i think they might have been down one i
think it was i think they was down
though
was they down was it three it wasn't
three one i can't i can't remember where
the series was at right but they was at
home and he's like yo come to the game
tonight i'm like nah because
the show that we have we getting some
bread i'm not missing that show i needed
that show
so he's like all right but that we could
have went to that [ __ ] we could have
went to that that [ __ ] bro
but also it was like we had like how
many people were like 15 people
like 15. i also say i don't think
anyone's ever faced harder competition
in the finals in lebron
yes and no so well yes and no because
you know what people
people always like oh michael jordan
played against jeff wanna say you know
it's like but john stockton one of the
toughest white boys to touch basketball
i just but
i just think of like lebron had to go
against
the first era of the peak spurs you know
seven
right then he had to go against kawhi
spurs this is with the heat
then then four straight years against
the warriors
it wasn't kawhi spurs when they won yeah
but kawhi was that [ __ ]
but it wasn't there wasn't like we
nobody even
thought that kawhi would you so he
played the spurs three times in the
finals
he played the thunder that had
three future mvps oh no okc is the worst
basketball organization
the fact they never got a ring is crap
not even that bro not even that
the fact that they paid sergey baka but
instead of james harden james
for two million dollars james harden was
63 65 and they offered him 63
and they said that they didn't want a
decision in oklahoma city
and they let him go but think about that
so he played that team which in
retrospect
is one of the most talented rosters ever
reggie jackson on that it was mad people
in that team the warriors four straight
years
three no it was four right it was four
it was four yeah so four strings
and then they won and then they lost
again twice mind you the first year that
he lost
kyrie and love weren't playing he had
matt he was telling him about giving him
the mvp
anyway and andre iguodala [ __ ] got
the mvp because steph was kind of
whatever in that yo but look
step that's the one thing about stuff
too yo steph doesn't have
never i just had this argument with this
[ __ ] not only does he not
but listen but i love steph curry now
only does he never got a finals mvp not
only does he have a
then i have a finance mvp he doesn't he
has a lot of clutch shots in the season
he don't have those
shots in the finals just was yelling at
this [ __ ] about this
he's not the goat he's not he's changing
the world
he's the most influent i think steph
curry's and i'm not talking about
culture he's the greatest
person i don't know if anyone's ever
influenced the way basketball's played
like he has yes who michael jordan bro
but but think about the last eight years
the whole game has changed with the way
people shoot
the animals you play in the white people
play ball when you was a kid yeah
bro do you remember the trouble you were
getting if you shot a [ __ ] three
you would get your coach would be on
your head yo not even on a fast break
because nobody shot threes on fast
breaks but i'm talking about i remember
one time general
that's a bad shot and i shot a three
from the corner i did it was in the
first quarter i didn't play again the
whole game
and now and i almost made it i almost
made the [ __ ]
he's just created a whole he's changed
basketball he does
i don't i think more than anyone as far
as just how it's played
how it's played yes i'ma tell you how
because
because of lebron james and lebron's
lebron's my personal
favorite player ever because of lebron
james being the height
he's the size of car malone he's a
monster he's the size of carl malone and
he runs as fast as allen iverson it's
crazy so that's what i'm saying so
after i feel like after lebron is when
aau because you know this [ __ ] is a
ground up business yeah where aau
started looking at kids because when we
were kids if you was the tallest kid all
you was taught is stand in and do this
jump up and down cash rebounds you can't
even take a shot for real
right facts now the big man has to know
how to dribble
now the big man has to know how to pass
they train the kids to know everything
and i think that that's because lebron
that's fair that's fair that's cause
lebron i always say
if i ask somebody who's the greatest of
all time and their answer isn't either
michael jordan or lebron james then they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about what
because who else is it kareem maybe wait
hold up
and i don't give a [ __ ] what people
think about the feelings of the
situation
kevin durant might go down as the
greatest scorer i i think
him or him or james harden yeah james
harden too but kevin
the thing about kevin durant is i think
the only edge he has on
on james is his hype because at his
height
he's another one that changed the game
too where
aau started looking at kids like oh no
we got to start telling these kids dude
you know what i mean yo it's crazy to
think that we're like alive to watch
both of them play at the same time hard
like the probably the two they're going
to probably go down to the two greatest
scores ever
but that's why braun is like
people well kobe that's why i always
equate wayne to kobe
because wayne i mean braun has played in
so it's brian drake yeah okay absolutely
jace jordan yeah yeah lebron wayne is
definitely kobe because wayne
wayne got a song that's enough nobody
can do a versus against wayne bro
it's impossible you can't no don't tell
drake
come on no bro i was at the drake
wrestling tour and i was like damn drake
got way more
just joints but bro i don't know who
selected his records but bro but
wayne has a record in think about
basketball no he's got a record in every
area
real quick real quick yeah think about
basketball think about wayne's music in
every basketball era
no you're right hit record he's had he's
had records in every era and every ever
i did not disagree every ever bro i
don't like drake is gonna be the evolved
version of wayne
i mean as an artist is what i mean who
do you think
fully healthy you think the lakers are
are taking it this year if they're fully
healthy absolutely
[ __ ] you katie my man but got it like
dragging that book and [ __ ] and yeah
and then they ain't got james out
there's no defense there's no defense in
the nba period
no but but but except for on the lakers
because they're [ __ ] top five
defensive team without a.d and lebron
since since they've been out
yo frank vogel low-key
when they hire frank vogel i was like
but but nah
but he was firing indiana but that's all
i was about to say
if i hate the word if
but because there's a point in time with
paul george bro i love paul
paul george is my favorite player not no
more look at look at the dawn lucas the
baby go do me and you are [ __ ] i
always tell everybody
luca might go down as the greatest of
all time luke is definitely gonna be the
greatest white man to play basketball
evan
it's year three but but like but he got
to win some though he got no he's got he
will
but but but that pacers team
bro they had to go up against miami i
guess
they gave him hell bro i get upset when
i'm playing 2k online and somebody picks
miami and i got
i get upset bro cuz i [ __ ] hate that
but
that indiana team was stacked top to
bottom that's when
danny granger wasn't sweet granger was
nice
this was roy roy hibbert was decent
before the big man was extinct
and and then remember when brad hibbert
found his groove
lance stevenson was a nice all-around
george hill was giving a lot of people
hell no no the pacers i remember i
remember i was like legit scared for
lebron one of those years i think when
they met in the eastern conference
finals
i was like oh yeah that [ __ ] went with
david west what david what
they just want to fight everybody i
would like to see david west
and uh celebrity blacksmith and and and
uh what's the lg on the [ __ ] heat
that's been on the haslem that would be
a fight that would be a real like
i paid money to see has one versus yeah
because i heard david west is like a
black belter so i've already like got
like seriously
saying that but i ain't seen no action
that's fair man well look man i
appreciate you coming through
um your podcast is every thursday every
thursday hear me out with wayne oh it's
on all platforms
please make sure that you rate and
review that's important
rates and reviews are very very
important even more and
hit the like on the youtube hit the
likes share it all i really care about
is if you see it and you like it you
feel like something
resonates share it you know i mean
please just share it
my [ __ ] is rooted in the people because
i am one of them there it is i mean
we'll go go go support in triangle
offense.com no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no
get your the clothes and [ __ ] it's not
out yet okay it's not out it's coming
when it comes we me and you do a little
15 minutes all right you know i mean we
talk some basketball again there it is
because i feel like we could do a whole
hour with my basketball
for sure but we do that and we do some
triangle offensive but the merch is
coming everybody who just if you [ __ ]
wayno thank you
kev i really appreciate you brother
trying to make this happen thank you